the rainforest home to this noise and
believe it or not these sounds may be
the key to saving it welcome to the
callee mantan rainforests of Borneo
Indonesia one of the most biodiverse
places on the planet
this is dr. Eddie game his job is
focusing on how to use technology to
understand the damage that mining and
logging is doing to the rainforest how
well by listening to it bio acoustic
monitoring is essentially just using the
sounds we hear from the environment as a
measure of environmental health yeah
busy arist or any other kind of
environment it's lots of animals making
noise think food insects frogs very
vocal ones that you hear are primates
from the mammal side the team uses a bio
acoustic monitor it's basically a smart
microphone they then have to track ours
through the forest deploying around 20
devices in a day we deploy them through
a lot of the forests of Borneo are
usually very mountainous very steep very
wet and there are no tracks where we're
putting them so most of the time it's
just us sort of slogging through the
forest until we find a place where we
want to quit and then we literally strap
it to a tree and set it to record and
walk away because the rain forest is so
dense it's almost impossible to track
all the creatures at any given time
which is why Eddy listens to the sounds
[Music]
the soundscape is
as we start to degrade environments
chopping down trees clearing areas
things like that hunting with losing
species and we see those gaps appear in
the soundscape when we measure the team
will then talk to forestry companies and
communities and provide guidance on the
best way to continue logging safely in
Indonesia what we want to make sure is
that we get the best conservation
outcome possible when you're actually
inside these forests and Rebecca tall
and they're dark and they're very noisy
it often surprises people to just have
no easier healthy forests is you usually
think of nature as somewhere that's a
place of a quietness or stillness then
that's true in certain circumstances
putting your in and prime healthy
rainforests one of the things that
really is an assault on the senses is
just how continuously noisy
[Music]